hi everybody hi
i'm john uh so i'm going to talk about
doing streaming data analysis online
learning and so
really just to give you some sense about
this my interest in these topics began
when suddenly i found myself in front of
the raw twitter firehose
and i was like well how am i going to
start doing interesting data analysis on
this
i'm now reading in multiple billions of
tweets every day
this is just not going to be possible
analyze the way i'm used to
and so i started really focusing on
things that i think if you have a sort
of statistical background
or even a machine learning background
you often sort of have not been trained
well to do which is to deal with
extremely small memory constraints or
also the size of your data
so just to get a quick show of hands of
a bunch of topics that are sort of going
to come up
let me see a few things so like how
people feel like they're on top of the
idea of space and time complexity
like raise your hand be like yeah that's
that's totally familiar to me concept
yeah so this is like there are
definitely some programmers among you
but sort of there are lots of people who
have probably more stats background
so what i mean by this is you know given
that i give you n observations how long
is it going to take you to process your
data
if it's going to take you a long time
that's its time complexity it's going to
require a lot of ram that's its space
complexity
and the goal of what i'm going to
present is to try to talk about a bunch
of algorithms that have very low
space complexity things that require a
very low amount of ram
or more importantly a constant amount of
ram relative the amount of data you want
to process
and the big insight of this is basically
going to be do gradient descend
one observation at a time this is sort
of the two tldr version of my talk is
doing that
but to give you a feel of the kind of
things i actually thought i would just
shine
show off this thing that i discovered
the other day that uh jason davies put
on his website
i think it gives an amazing feel for the
kind of stuff that i'm going to talk
about
which is sort of hacky but brilliant
probabilistic computations that do
really really simple things that seem
that they should be impossible otherwise
so this is a a visualization of a bloom
filter so how many people
raise your hand if you know what a bloom
filter is and if enough people here do
all right so i'm gonna so i'm gonna
actually do this but i'll go super fast
so i don't bother people who do know
the idea of the bloom filter is real
simple i have this data set
it's streaming in and i just wanna know
given the new item
and i'm going to memorize a bunch at the
start have i already seen this item
or have i not so i'm just going to say
give me a bunch of elements
i now want to be able to test set
inclusion on a stream of data
and i want to be able to do this in a
way that's fairly
simple in terms of memory so i don't
want to store if i want to like say if i
want to memorize
100 million items i don't want to have
to store 100 million items in memory i
want to store something that's a very
small amount of memory
and the trick with the boom filter is
very simple you have this
little thing filled with memory and
these are all just bits they're either
zeros or ones
and the question basically comes is
something in it or is it not so the
trick is that you have a bunch of hash
functions
so say i put in my name john now i add
this to this
well john hashes under three different
hash functions
to a set of numbers say that for this
example pretend that they're 17
19 and 21 i now fill in the bits
17 19 and 21
into this data structure and from that
point on if you ask me is john in there
well if i ask yeah john isn't there and
the reason for that is i will just hash
john again see that it produces the bits
19 and 21 and check that they're on
if something is in the data structure if
something has been memorized by this
filter
i take this hash i get the hash of it
and i check if all of the bits are on
if all of the bits are on the thing
probably was seen there's a possibility
of a false positive
but there is no possibility ever of a
false negative
and this is it and that's that's the
bloom filter the rest i'm going to talk
about is a bunch of algorithms that are
all of this sort
the things that solve sort of simple
questions that otherwise seem very
difficult
like you know how do i do this where i'm
not telling you in advance how many
things you have to memorize
and be able to do this efficiently so
let's get started online active learning
and data streams
so let's introduce these so first we've
got online and active learning
and the way i really like to introduce
these is with multi-arm bandit problem
so the multi-arm band problem is really
really common if you run in anything
that's like a website if you run some
sort of startup
everything you deal with is like a
multi-armed band a problem
which is say um i've got to decide what
ad i want to show
to all my users today do i want to show
them ad a or do i want to show them
add b how do i decide this well there's
the obvious thing i'm just going to run
some randomized experiments
but a multi-armed bandit says i've got
two options a
and b i want to start to learn and
gradually prefer
option a if a is superior and mostly
show a the user is coming in from that
point on
so i want to both run an experiment and
then act on that experiment
and the trick about this is that it's
online
i want to be learning about whether a or
b is superior that's what i mean by
online is that i want to be learning
that
in real time and i want to have an
answer at every point in time
so if i see one user i want to know
after user one
do i think a or b is better and if i see
a second user i want to update my
beliefs and have a new sense of whether
a or b
is superior i don't want to be just
pushing this off into some batch mode
that sort of you know having run the
experiment and it's over i now can
analyze it
i want to be doing my analysis in real
time while the experiment is running
active learning is something i'm not
going to focus on very much in this talk
but active learning is the next step up
which is not only am i
figuring out which one is better but i'm
also figuring out what things i want to
be exploring
in the future that's what makes it
active which you decide what you want to
learn
and if you want to do active learning
you always need to be able to do online
learning
and so you need to have good tools for
doing learning online
so here are the what i would identify as
the basic requirements for doing online
learning the model has to be able to
survive cold starts
this means that a lot of sort of very
naive frequencies things won't work
if i just start running a and b and i
have no idea whether a or b are superior
i have no data and so sort of not
obvious what i'm going to do
one obvious trick is that you use some
sort of simple prior and you just say
you know before i know anything i assume
they both have clicked the rate of zero
percent
and then everything at that point on is
going to be better by definition
and gradually you're going to learn from
there in addition which is this is
really a definition of online
the model has to be ready to make
up-to-date predictions after every
observation
and this is the thing that's going to
really stand out about the stochastic
grading descent that i'm going to talk
about later
which is every single time i see one
observation i want it to affect my model
i don't want to have to wait for huge
batches i want to be able to do
something immediately
and in order to make that work model
updates the steps that actually work
every single
observation they need to be very cost
effective and then i mean two things by
this
one that i don't ever have to go back
through all the historical data
i want to be able to just use my current
beliefs to figure out what to do next
i don't want to have to reread anything
and then two
i want to not do a lot of work on every
observation
so it shouldn't be like you know given
one new observation
i rerun all the model fitting i have
ever done that's just too costly i want
something that's kind of a quick hack
and what you're going to see is that i'm
going to give you a quick hack
but it's a very well established quick
act that really was invented in the
1950s
the other context in which this comes up
is data streams and this is something
that the database community
is really thinking a lot about these
days and so the data streams comes up
because
increasingly we deal with data sets that
are too large to fit in ram if you're
google
maybe everything fits in ram but if
you're anyone else
at some point your data set doesn't fit
in ram you need to figure out what
you're going to do with it
and the problem with this is that
especially if you've grown up using r
r has just no capacity at all to deal
with this there are people building
packages on top of r to deal with this
but natively this is just not nr and the
reality is it's not anywhere else it's
not like somehow if you went to some
other language like python you're going
to find this
they're starting to put that into other
tools but really no one
nowhere has provided a really clean way
of doing analysis that's not in batch
mode
but the problem is we have to do it
somehow we have to be able to process
memory that we process data that we
can't fit in memory somehow we have to
find some way to do these kind of
analyses
and so my claim is this you want to use
algorithms of small memory footprint
which is why i showed you that bloom
filter early on the blue filter is
nicely this one that is an incredibly
small memory
proof memory footprint and the other
thing is i want to deal with data that
streams in one observation at a time
and what i mean by stream is it comes in
i process it
and there's no guarantee i will ever get
to see it again that's what
distinguishes a stream from a database
is that there's no guarantee that data
will be stored
uh maybe i'm the nsa i see your data but
i don't get to keep it but i've got to
do something with it
all right so there are really obvious
things i'm actually going to use the
first of these the mean
to describe how you might do this so
there's some really simple statistics
you can easily do using 01 memory
this means just some constant amount of
memory it doesn't depend on whether i
have
five observations or five trillion
observations
calculating means variance skewness
kurtosis
these just require a constant number of
bits
john d cook has a really really great
blog post where he goes through code to
calculate all of these things
they get progressively more subtle but
they're all pretty easy they're all like
basically an hour of coding time to make
algorithms that do this in constant
memory
john d cook john d cook and it's
something like uh
running stamps maybe that's the name of
the code
basically if you look up online meme
you'll almost certainly find this post
in contrast and this is why i showed
this bloom filter
lots of other things are really
difficult although there are
approximations that are possible without
storing
basically the whole data set memory so
medians is an obvious example but unique
item counts
which is not quite what bloom filter
does but something very similar
hyperloglog is doing this
which is just i want to know how many
different users say visited my site over
the last
year well i can't actually store all
their names except maybe in some log
files it's really hard to get access to
and i definitely can't do this in some
way where i'm going to store
the id of every user i've ever seen in
ram i mean maybe you can get away from
some places but generally this is a bad
idea and so what you need to do is do
something clever
but the problem is these things are
really clever i mean hyperloglog is
is actually an incredibly elegant and
beautiful 10-page paper to read
but it's also a modern research paper
published in the last 25 years
uh you know doing these kind of things
is subtle um and really what it comes
down to is is there some clever graduate
student or professor who wrote a
probabilistic data structure to solve
your problem
if there isn't basically go home that's
sort of you know that's really what it
comes down to
except in the special case and special
cases that i want to reason about
complex models
and complex models i sort of by
definition if they're complex
some graduate student isn't writing
research papers about them because
they're not his complex model
they're yours and so no one else is
spending their time
trying to specialize how to do analysis
on that complex model
and so we really the question is how do
we fit those fast and with little memory
and so the claim i'm going to have is
that most people now accept that the
state of the r is an algorithm called
stochastic gradient descent or sgd
and that this is for instance what valpo
webbit does if you've ever used velvet
wabbit but many other tools are using
this and it's
unbelievably simple intellectually this
is part of what's awesome about it is
this is a tool that will just go forever
on from you you leave today
and you have complicated models that you
want to fit a huge web scale
you can just use sgd and you're sort of
fine
i guess i should say sort of because the
smg is kind of messy but it's at least
intellectually simple
so let's build up to the std slowly by
thinking about how you compute
means by using constant memory so
the really simplest way of tracking a
mean is the definition
we're all used to from math class which
is the mean of
n data points x1 through xn is just i
take the sum of them and divide by
n this is sort of the obvious way that
you might think about doing this
and in code and this is julia code it
looks a little like this
you have the mean of a vector is first i
start with zero
i figure out its length i loop through
every one of them add them all together
and then i divide by n now there's an
obvious problem with this this algorithm
is not online as stated it gives you no
useful answers until you've gone through
all n data points
and that's i mean there's an obvious
problem with it that's easy to fix which
is i just not doing the division along
the way i could have done that
division but as stated this thing is
just not doing something that would ever
give you a real-time answer you always
have to process
all the data before you're done but
there's a really obvious reformulation
of this problem
in terms of very simple algebraic tricks
that will give you a different version
and this is the recursive definition of
the mean
so the mean of n data points is n minus
one divided by n times the mean of n
minus one of the data points plus one
over n
times the last data points and this
definition
is basically the sgd and we're going to
talk way more about
why this is the sgd but this is
basically the trick
and the trick is i have some belief at
time n
and the belief at time n is generated by
my belief of time n
minus 1 plus some trivial update based
on what happened at time
end and here is exactly the trivial
update to do that if you have means
so what if n is really big and one over
n
is below machine precision you stop
learning
uh yeah there are other types where you
need to really think a little bit about
what you're going to do
but i mean it's sort of unbelievable i
mean because there exist
cases in which you could get an end so
that this is not going to work
but i mean the end in which if him is
before the end in which this starts
stops working is like
way bigger than the number of people on
earth and when you're getting a number
of transactions
completely stopped but it kind of goes
away from what you think it should be
because of the
machine precision right before it
completely fails it actually starts
lying
okay it was very compared to the
original formula
i mean it definitely it definitely does
do that at some point but i mean i think
if you're having that problem machine
precision is sort of cheap to
double like if you're dealing with
things where all you needed was to go up
to 128 bit floats
find somebody who's going to make 128
bit float chip for you
and you're gonna you know and that's
sort of that's going to solve most of
your problems you know like
by the time you get to 256 bits i would
be very surprised if you had any problem
anywhere because there aren't enough
atoms in the universe for you to be
finding problems beyond 256-bit floats
like there aren't enough atoms for you
to be actually using 64 bits of floats
but you know they're certainly not
enough atoms for you to go past 256.
i think there's not even well i guess
there are enough atoms to use 64 bit
ants but
certainly not floats
how do you start that what's your first
uh
so the message yeah so i it really
depends on the exact application you
want
i'm gonna pretend for the rest of my
talk that i always start things at zero
so but it does really depends like um in
the bandit case
if you do this kind of rule for updating
it's really important for many
practical applications that you started
with a very optimistic guess of what the
mean is
and this um yeah we'll talk later if you
want to know why that's true but sort of
it really depends on your application
how you want to start this thing
yeah so there are actually others that
are slightly more robust numerically i
think than this one
um
this one is really simple and is going
to be also how you get to the sgd like
it's it's going to obviously generalize
to that
and so just to show you sort of obvious
code to do this and this is just you
know this is just that equation written
in code
this is something you could do and the
nice thing is that if you're using this
kind of code at every point in time and
every deviation
m is actually a usable mean you could be
doing something with
and so this really simple update rule is
actually usable it will both give you
the right
idea and be usable online but the thing
i really like about this and why i use
this specific form
is that we could think of this in a much
more general context
which is this sort of convex combination
rule i've got my beliefs at time
n i've got some constant alpha which is
how much i weight
what's coming into me which is xn and
then i'm also just one minus alphas how
much i keep with my previous beliefs
and this you know in this context when
we're doing the exact correct
frequentest mean
alpha of n is going down like one over n
but
and i'm going to claim the important
thing is thinking about generalizations
from there
and so let's think about the obvious
generalization and the obvious
generalization which is actually
not in some sense more general but
somehow just different
is to drop off the dependency on n and
just have some constant value of alpha
so now alpha just is some constant
period that i've established
and if you know this formula play around
with it if you're not familiar with it
this is the exponentially weighted
average version of averages
it's going to progressively increase the
importance of recent events
and so you're always sort of going to
slowly forget things that happened in
the past
and this formula is exactly the std this
is exactly a way of solving the sdg for
this very simple case
and so let's look at it to see that well
let's first look at this behavior
so here's a graph where i have a
moving target i'm trying to track the
mean of the blue thing which is this
random block
and the problem with trying to track the
mean of this blue thing is that
it doesn't have an actual fixed mean
it's constantly moving
and so using the frequentest version
which is the
red line here it will actually be able
to track things if things move slow
enough but it goes
really slow and doesn't do a great job
in contrast my other thing where i fixed
alpha to be some constant
i'm actually much better able to track
fluctuations in this
and that how well i do depends a lot on
alpha
i picked alpha here sort of sort of does
a good job of mimicking it
but if i do a bad job of picking alpha i
will just smooth everything
or i'll only remember the most recent
observation i won't have anything useful
and actually unfortunately that that
statement is actually just going to be
endemic through the entire rest of this
discussion about how to use the svd
which is picking the step size alpha is
basically always a problem you have to
deal with
there are starting to be better
solutions to it but it's not a solved
problem yet
but my claim is that in many contexts
what you actually might want
is this slight generalization the
version where you have alpha be some
arbitrary constants
and here's one reason you might think
that's a cool idea
let's just rewrite the equation i wrote
so the equation i wrote was that m of n
is one minus alpha times n minus time m
of n minus one
plus alpha of x n and just shifting
things around this is exactly the same
thing as saying that
m of n is like m at n minus 1
plus alpha times the difference between
what i saw
and what my previous beliefs would have
seen and this is what people in the
reinforcement literature
reinforcement learning literature call a
prediction error
and the svg is exactly this and we're
going to prove that this is actually the
gradient of this function in just a
second
but the idea basically is every time i'm
trying to make good predictions that's
what my beliefs are for
at every point in time you're going to
see whether i'm doing a good job
and then i'm going to head in the
direction that would make me do a better
job
i'm always going to try to do slightly
better i'm going to move in the gradient
that leads me to making better decisions
and that's exactly what this formula
looks like the sqd is just going to be
this principle
used in other contexts
and so here's the reason imagine that i
have a loss function
and my loss function is given some
constant n and some data sets
i figure out how much i've mispredicted
things along the way
and that's just like taking the sum and
then for here i've intentionally scaled
it by one half because it just makes the
calculus easier
but i'm taking the sum of x i's minus m
and squaring them
and this is presumably very familiar to
everyone as a classical statistics
education this is just a standard
sum of squared errors thing that you see
over and over and over again
but the relevant thing is if i have that
loss function then the gradient is just
a negative version of x i minus m this
prediction error
my failure in my prediction is the scale
as the
negated version of the gradients
and if i'm going to do gradient descent
what i want to do is go in the negative
version of it
and so it's literally just going to be x
i minus sound
so the gradient over the entire data i
would ever have seen
is just all of the x i's minus m's
summed up
for any m that i choose and the trick
that i'm going to do and i'm just going
to reiterate this over and over again
through this talk
the trick is just going to be doing that
but only looking at one of them
instead of looking at the sum of all the
differences i'm just going to look at a
single one
x i minus m at every point in time and
use that as an approximation of the
gradient
and then move in that direction and if
that makes sense to you already
it's sort of you're done like sort of
there's nothing left in this talk if
that's totally clear to you
but presumably sort of a little more
information would be useful to you
and this is just rewriting this so this
is saying that formula i wrote which is
looking at
the updates at time n is like my
previous beliefs and then
some scaled version of my prediction
error that's really like saying that my
updates are my previous beliefs
plus something that takes me in the
negative gradients something that takes
me a little bit in that direction
and so this is this is stochastic
gradient to set
so the thing that makes it stochastic in
this case is just looking
at the single contribution from x i
not looking at all of the data all at
once but only looking at a single data
point and
each time and this is the sdd for
tracking means
and in fact it's exactly the same as if
i had just drawn gradient descent so if
you've learned how to do gradient
descents to try to fit models
this is exactly that algorithm there is
no difference between them
this is just a hack that lets you do it
so you every single observation you have
an updated version of your model
there's nothing else that's distinct
about this
and that's because simple calculus tells
us the gradient over all of the
observations is the sum of the
observations
per observation gradients and that's
that's all that matters is the sort of
nice linearity of how
calculus works now
the full sdd algorithm introduces a
little bit of randomness which is
if you had a fixed data set i would
randomly draw
x side at any given point i would just
go into a bucket of doubt values x
i i just pull out a random one and then
use that to do this updating rule
and that is that is it i mean that is
literally the entire sgd algorithm for
this case
and you'll see that this is it for every
other case so let's talk about sgd
so the way i want to do it is to build
up gradually doing
stochastic gradient descent for linear
regression
and so maybe no one maybe you're not
familiar with it but i claim that this
is what linear regression is linear
regression is this equation and if you
ever have a chance to read a book on
optimization theory this is the way
optimization people will just frame it
many statisticians would but this is
definitely the way optimization people
which is
i have a loss function given some
parameters beta
and beta is my mapping that goes from x
my inputs to my predictions y
and what i'm trying to do is just take y
minus x transpose beta
and fit and find the minimum version of
that
in the squared norm and this is exactly
what we did before
and this is just writing in the simple
notation and if i have it this way
well then its gradient is just well its
version which is a summation and this is
really what matters
and so far i sort of have left this
implicit but let me make this very clear
the trick about using sgd if you're
going to try to use it in practice for
something you care about is that you
need to use it on models
where the loss function over all of your
data
is the sum of the exact same function
applied at every data point
if every data point is treated the same
way and you're just
summing up errors per data points to get
your entire loss function
then everything i say will just carry
through and there's no need for
modifications
if that's not true you're just in a much
much more complicated situation and
i mean we can talk later but things are
going to be bad in general if you're
just sort of not having the property
thankfully almost every statistical
model you care about is this i was going
to say can you give some examples where
you'd in which you think that data is
not all independent
so if you think like the observations
are not all independent draws
then that's a bad place and markov
models would be an example of something
like that
that that's a that's a case where sort
of you don't think every single one of
them is the same
and so you can't just sort of pull one
of them
by itself and then add them all up i got
a bunch of questions
yeah you've got a question in georgette
so any model which you think is
probabilistically generating data and
every data
every data point is iid then the log
likelihood
will be a summation of the likelihood of
every term
and all of them will have the same
likelihood
yeah so that i mean i'm totally glossing
over the fact that if you try to deal
with non-convex problems you also have
problems
but if you deal with non-complex
problems in general there are bad things
coming for you
it's typical of some but not necessarily
i mean i mean
here's an obvious example of a
non-linear thing that it's not typical
of it's not typical of logistic
regression
but just aggression is totally convex
and profoundly non-linear
um yeah i mean if
if you think that you are dealing with a
problem that is not on this list and
you're not sure whether this works
i guess i have to i guess i have two
answers one is you should maybe think a
little about what you're doing
and another one is often it doesn't
matter whether you actually got the real
optimum
like um like all the neural net people
the neural net people are like not
actually trying to find global optima
if they get there it's awesome but often
they just care that their model at a
local optimum is doing better than other
people's global optima
yeah it is definitely important to say
that um yeah
all right so the important thing here is
that for this
linear regression case i'm just looking
at the sum of squared errors
and so every one of them looks like this
my
prediction which i just get some linear
prediction and i just look at the
residual
and then that is basically going to be
my gradient and let's just see that
you know exactly the gradient is just
going to be the residual
y i minus x x trans x i transpose beta
times x i this is the gradient
and then you just go home and convince
yourself of this because this is not
familiar to you it's like
a sort of very valuable exercise to do
this at some point for yourself
but this is what every one of the terms
error contribution is which is just and
it really should be i think very
intuitive it's just saying
how much do i need to change my beliefs
well i need to change my beliefs in
response to two things how big an error
i made which is the residual
y i minus x x i beta and then another
thing
how big each of the x i components was
so if one of the terms in my regression
model was really big and i made a big
error
then i should really change that one's
coefficient if in contrast it was really
small and i made a big error
it probably isn't responsible as much as
the other ones that are big
so you know focusing energy on things
that are mostly causing the problems
and then mostly change your beliefs when
things have big problems so that's the
way you can
intuitively remember this gradient
and so gradient descent would be that at
every iteration
you're just going to update beta at time
t to be
its previous version of t minus one and
let's just assume as i said earlier that
beta at
zero is just all zeros just a vector of
zeros everywhere
and at every point in time i just move
along the negative gradients
of distance eta and if you know
good gradient descent code and i'm
actually sort of going to go
fast thanks i'm going to go pretty fast
so i'm actually not going to go through
the code for this and just sort of stick
to the math
well how many people know what a line
search is
like and how many people are like yeah
i've coded a line search algorithm
yeah so not many people have done this
so this is gradient descents if you use
ada to be the same value all the time in
every iteration
it will eventually get where it's going
to go most of the time
sometimes you'll have problems with
floating points and other things
but it's just really slow and
inefficient a better way to do this in
professional
radiant descent software which sort of
there isn't that much of it because it's
not a great algorithm
but if you were using professional
software to do this
it would choose data at every iteration
in a custom way that would be more
appropriate and that's what a line
search algorithm is going to figure out
what ada is
and that really does matter we're going
to deal with the fact that we are not
really smart enough to figure out how to
do that and for sgd
and it generally is the case that people
have not yet figured out how to set
these in an intelligent way
and just use them as constants and let
computers hopefully make up for it by
running longer
to sort of we we're not great at it but
computers can do a lot so let's just let
computer students
so this is gradient descents and
stochastic gradient descent in this
model is well here's the code let me
skip this i'll just focus on the sgd
code which will be almost identical but
sort of more relevant
john sorry can you go back to the slides
there may be literature in which it has
that interpretation but i have never
read it
uh but that does not preclude its
existence just that i'm not familiar
with it
i mean it's yeah we can talk later about
sort of what you should be doing at
every iteration and what the logic of
what ada is supposed to be but it's sort
of
it's just the distance you should go to
minimize the function of that iteration
that's what it is
if the function you're trying to
minimize is convex
then running this from any starting
point will eventually converge to the
true optimum
that's that is that is the relevant
theoretical claim this will eventually
get to the truth
as t goes to infinity the value squared
norm will go to zero
i mean the difference between t and t
minus one is one and the distance
between nor
the distance between betas is going to
be the euclidean norm
that's and that's i mean if you want i'm
happy to give you references about the
exact definition of
conversion so the convergence is going
to be this thing is exactly the same as
the true value
it's going to get there at the true
optimum eventually as t goes to infinity
that's that's the theoretical coin
there's nothing probabilistic so far i
have nothing i said is probabilistic so
that's
sort of a red hair um
i did say that but that's also not i
mean
if i i sort of want to not get way late
on this because i think it's a sort of
technical issue but sort of
all reasonable models that if i only run
the whole that i personally respect
this will work and if you're using a
model but this won't work i think you
shouldn't be using that model
uh i mean i think that's and it sort of
doesn't depend on auto correlations
because this is just a property of
convexity of functions
it'll yeah so it'll still it'll still
work on this sort of
it's really like only if your function
has like weird problems that sort of
it's got for instance
it's not identifiable if your model is
not identifiable this won't work but i
think
people who use non-inflammatory think of
their models
um all right let's let's sort of not get
too slow down i guess i should have
allocated more time to spend on
classical gradient descent
i think it's more interesting and it's
so similar to go through the theory of
svd so let's just focus on that and
it'll be basically the same thing so
we'll skip the gd code
so the spd trick is this and this partly
solves you're concerned about
autocorrelation which is
at every point in time i'm going to draw
one of the observations randomly and
this is the theory where this is
definitely going to work is that i just
draw something randomly from a bucket
if they're coming in streaming on a
website that's not necessarily true
basically that's just hope you hope that
that works but sort of no guarantees
that it's going to be true but in a
theoretical case and i'm going to
implement code that does exactly this
i'm going to assume that i have a bucket
of data that it's too big to fit in
memory so i can't process all of it
but at any given point in time i can
pull in and reach one row out of my
database
and this is actually i mean in the case
in which i have used these techniques
which is dealing with things like the
twitter fire hose
it is not in fact the case that i can
never go back and get the fire hose
i have all of it it's just the case that
i can't store all of it in ram
at one point and so i just pull a chunk
of it in work on that chunk
put it back down and then pull another
random chunk and the randomness is what
solves the concern you have
but even then i mean as long as you use
a fixed
data sets eventually these things should
work
uh there are there are definitely
problems and they are brittle but they
will sort of from figure out the track
of their work
so let's actually like uh let's show
that so the sgd is going to be
instead of looking at the gradients over
all the things it's christianly used
just with the gradients at a single term
so here is how you this is the sgd
equation to do
linear regression if you want to fit a
linear regression on any data sets that
you're going to stream
just use this update rule so at every
point in time you update your current
betas
what do you do you move a distance eta
towards y minus x i transpose beta
x i you just go in the direction of your
error
and then just try to minimize that error
one by one observation by observation
and let's go through code to make it
very clear how that works
so here's code and this is going to
mutate a vector so i have
data x is my matrix of data
y is my vector of responses b is my
vector of parameters
eta is this constant and then g r is my
store of what i'm going to put the
gradient in i actually don't need to
store the gradient but i'm just going to
use it
and here's what i do and this is julia
code so it sort of looks very matlab
so the first thing i do is figure out
how many parameters p there are
and how many observations i have n so
that's p and the size of x
so this is just saying that all of the
columns are observations
and then each column has p rows because
it has p dimension
p different features that i'm trying to
use uh
did i yes is that transposed yes this is
the transpose of what you would do if
you were using r say this is
this is just more efficient in julia
because it has the way it stores data
but this is the transpose of how
one often thinks of data
and then given that i know how many
observations there are i just generate a
random number between
one and n that's j that's the
observation we're going to look at
that's the thing i'm going to pull out
of the buckets
and then from then on it's going to work
on just that observation
and so h is my prediction so i take the
dot product
of the features for the jth observation
and v my current parameters
then i calculate the residual y of j
minus h
the gradient is just that residual times
all the features for the j
observation and then i update theta by
doing
by plot you know by plus equaling it so
taking beta is beta plus
eta times the gradients this is exactly
the equation we just saw before just
written in code and this is going to
just mutate this thing which is why i
have this exclamation mark
as you can see ipython notebook is not
fond of exclamation marks or of greek
letters
but i am so they're there
and then the outer loop that does this
is going to look just like this
i'm going to have my data x y eta which
i fixed and here i'm just giving you
some
example value you could have set it to
some small number like zero zero one
but no claim is made that this is the
value that's going to work for you
uh and the number of iterations i want
to make and for here i'll say just a
thousand
and then here what i do is i look at the
size of the data i pre-allocate
my initial estimates of the coefficients
which are just all zeros
i pre-allocate the grade gradient which
is just all zeros
i figure that i'm currently at iteration
zero and then i just make this while
loop where every iteration i count that
i've done one more iteration
and then do the thing we just saw and
this is it i mean
this is stochastic gradient descent for
linear regression you know those two
functions
if you can figure out how to make them
scale for your data set and whatever you
need to do
that's it there's so there's no more
magic left to fitting linear regression
so so in the case where this is
streaming data the max integer
wouldn't be bounded exactly so in case
of streaming data
you're going to have this thing just
constantly running all the time and say
just while true is going to be this loop
and then
presumably in that case you want to have
something that also has
access to b so that something can do
something with beta at every point in
time um
so and so people who sort of have done
this at large scale and gone this work
in production systems
they felt a lot of that sort of what is
the mechanism that's communicating data
to the rest of the world to make
predictions
and i think there was another hand um
it looks like we're not worried about
the same value again
so it's actually a good thing that we
sometimes pull the same value
um so it's so the thing that makes this
thing
so nice and actually solves the
autocorrelation problem
is that this thing is what it's actually
doing is at every point in time
its expected update is the expected
value of the gradient
that's actually the trick that makes
this the whole thing work is that the
expected value of the gradient
is actually the true gradient over the
whole data sets
and so the fact that i'm allowed to that
i'm sampling with replacements
that's actually really important because
that's what guarantees the expected
value of these updates is the true
gradient
and that's what guarantees that this
thing is actually doing the same thing
as gradient descent just sort of
in a different more randomized way does
that answer your question
right um but that so that's that is a
sort of
fairly subtle point like that that
randomness does actually matter
um and the one way you could think about
it is and i think
there's probably papers but i have yet
to read them that sort of are doing
things that make it clear the
relationship between the std and the
bootstrap but there is sort of a sort of
similar spirit between calculating the
s2d and like
bootstrap and gradient descent there's
something
very similar to sort of the way you
think about them yeah
this is kind of orthogonal to this
method but a lot of times
you know you want to scale your features
and in order to scale your features
you might need to know some properties
about them
is there sort of this parallel crazy
like
feature scaling streaming yeah so i'm
not gonna get to that so
so let's actually quickly talk about
right now let's talk about what when
this would go badly and
the first obvious case is the one you
just brought up so
um the first problem is that you have to
actually know the right value of eta
this this constant that deciding how far
you go at every iteration along the
gradient
it really matters it matters exactly as
much as that original graph i showed you
where i had really carefully hand tuned
alpha
and if i had said alpha to be something
else i would have sort of always gotten
the same constant
and if i had got an alpha to something
totally different i would have sort of
flopped randomly around space and never
learned anything
it really really matters that you set
data to the right values here
and so most people who try to do this
will have some sort of tricks sort of
either you say start with the sort of
very small subset of the data
read that explore a bunch of different
values of ada find the best value of
data and then use that for the rest of
the data
or you might do something like early
stopping where you're fitting most of
the stream
but then you have some held at cross
validation set where you're constantly
checking
and when you sort of see that you're
doing badly you stop trying to move in
the gradient anyway
there's all sorts of tricks to setting
ada but even when you set data to the
best possible value
the fact that the features may not all
have the same scale as a total killer
the thing that makes this bad is the
thing that in general makes gradient
descent bad
so if you've sort of sat down at some
point in your life and if you haven't i
totally encourage doing this if you sat
down and coded gradient descent
there are two obvious things that go
very badly for gradient descent
one is that some of the features are
really huge and some of the others are
really small
and so the gradient is just sort of
totally lopsided towards some of them
and not towards the others
and which makes sort of the ideal
setting of ada different for one of them
from the others
and that's sort of a huge problem and
i'm going to talk about one standard
solution which is what called people
call out of grad
which is which we actually set a
different data for every feature
and that's going to fix the fact that
they all have different scales because
you're going to set data relative to the
scale of every feature
and you can do that online that's out of
grand
and that's the first of the big problems
which is the fact that these things all
have
weird different scaling that really
screws up these systems
the other much deeper thing and i i feel
like the solutions to this other deeper
thing are not great yet
which is that if some of the features
are very very highly correlated
this thing starts to get progressively
worse and worse and worse
and that's actually also true of
gradient descent which is that if you
have really correlated features gradient
descent is
kind of a bad algorithm to use and it's
also really true here in sgd
and i'm so i don't think because we're
sort of running a little low on time but
i can maybe if i can pull it off i'll do
some live coding and some demos of this
stuff
i mean in cases in which those two
properties are not true in which
all the features more or less have the
same scale and things are not highly
correlated
s2d basically does exactly as well as
other model fitting techniques
which is pretty great because it runs
streaming when those things are true
when things are really correlated or
have really different scales sgd can be
pretty bad
um the problem basically is sort of it's
what we've got for dealing with
streaming data but it's still
like not a great solution
all right so now that i've given you all
the caveats let's
let's look through the rest of what i've
got so some let's just
i'll actually skip the matrix
factorization one because a little more
complicated
let's just look at this is the only
change required to that codes to make
something that solves logistic
regression instead of linear regression
so first i just need to write out this
function here that is the inverse logic
and then all i do that's different is
just
update the residuals in a different way
this is the only difference because this
is the
only difference that matters between
these models is they have slightly
different gradients
and this is the difference in their
gradients this is exactly what differs
between these two models
and so if you were trying to fit
classification model streaming
this is how you fit streaming logistic
regression
and so i think this is sort of really
why i like svd is that
as long as you feel like you know enough
calculus to do gradients
you know enough to fit arbitrary models
under streaming context
i think that's the thing that makes this
a really powerful technique
um these slides will be online but
here's an example where i
pulled code and just well i wrote code
that emulates
the math and one of the classic papers
on the netflix prize
so this is solving the matrix
factorization streaming and if you
looked at the netflix data you realize
that netflix 8 is one of these you also
probably can't fit in ram on your laptop
but thankfully this is the sort of easy
way to solve those kind of problems and
the trick basically is that it's just
linear regression but oscillates between
two different factors
let's talk a little about what goes
wrong so this already came up so
the fact that you have to choose this
constant step size ada
that's bad the fact you have to tune
this i mean anything that's tunable is
always just bad
things that are tunable are likely to go
wrong
good batch algorithms as i said use
these line search algorithms which will
set ada for you
we don't really have a great theory of
how to do that
when you're in the online setting we're
starting to have it um
brian d'alessandro when he heard i was
doing this talk wrote to me and said
we've been using recently
one of the things that john lankford has
published a paper on that works really
well
so people are starting to come up with
algorithms for setting ada
but it's something that's definitely an
active topic of research
um another problem sort of high quality
conversions so really getting exactly
the right thing
up to a bunch of significant digits
those are really slow compared to things
you might use in a batch setting
so the classic example in advanced
learning would be quasi-newton methods
and they need sort of the knowledge of
the hessian which is what solves these
correlations between features
svd is just not going to give you that
it's just going to give you an
approximate solution but it's not going
to sort of get the refined details in
general
and the other thing that's really
annoying is that if you're not careful
a lot of the time when you code up sqd
it's just going to completely break
and not like kind of break but just like
be totally useless
and this is because if you're not
careful that initial step that you make
on the very first iteration from ada
is going to take you really really far
because the gradient is really big
and then the problem is that the next
step the gradient to fix
that mistake is going to be even bigger
and just going to blow up and so
you know if you're even slightly off at
the setting of ada it's very easy that
you just wind up with ink as the value
of all of your coefficients
and this happens way more often than i
care to admit
which is why tuning eta which is the
first line really matters
that this will definitely happen in
production
yeah so it is saying definitely to try
to use that um and i'm actually going to
talk about what is sort of the analog to
momentum
so momentum is the concept from gradient
descent where basically
average gradients over time and there
are varieties of momentum
but they all sort of have that spirit of
being averages of gradients
the analog is what's sometimes called
polyacc averaging and that's going to be
basically the same thing and i have some
slides to show
how that works um yeah so let's let's
get to that but you know that is one
solution you might try to put into these
things
so i guess there's two points and leon
batu who's written a lot of really nice
papers about this topic really iterates
these points over and over again so i
think i should iterate them
sometimes low precision conversions is
actually a virtue
sometimes low precision actually kind of
winds up being like running
regularization even without having asked
for it
and the claim and i think this actually
is a true claim is that often bad
optimization algorithms are good
learning algorithms
that trying to find the exact best fit
to your data is not always a good thing
if your data is kind of bad and that
sometimes a kind of hacky fit to that
data may actually be more beneficial
and so i think that's another virtue is
that often these things actually give
good fits so let's talk a little bit
some tricks that exist for improving std
so one is you really should do this it's
decreased step sizes over time so i'll
talk a little bit how to do that
another smoothing estimates by averaging
which is basically momentum
and another setting learning rates per
parameter which is how to deal with the
fact that features have different scales
and that's at a grad
and there's you know there's literature
on all of these tricks
so the first one is actually very
classical so let's go back to thinking
about inferring the mean and sort of
what is the optimal thing that if the
thing is stationary you're just trying
to find the right mean what is the way
you should have been setting alpha
well if you were doing stationary data
set the right way to say alpha is that
at every point in time n alpha of n
should have been one over n you should
just gradually be decreasing this step
size
and that's actually a very general
principle there's a
proof by robinson monroe and i think
probably in earlier well actually you
know realms and rose a different paper
the same robin's i believe in the 50s
published the proof of this stained and
romans and rose something slightly
different
which is that in general if you want to
guarantee convergence for the sgd
you need to guarantee that alpha
decreases like one over n
um and there are slightly more it's
actually like it needs to decrease like
one over n but not
as fast as one over n squared it has to
be somewhere below
one over n squared but has to be at
least as fast as one over n
that's the theoretical claim required to
get actual conversions to the true
values
but if your data is not stationary
convergence is sort of much less
important
you've seen so far okay so yeah i guess
we we mean different things by the word
total but yes
it's the total you've seen of that of
the time and
all right and then you know so if you
read the literature you'll start to see
equations that look like this which is
that alpha then is that constant eta
but decreasing like one over n with
maybe some offsets
tau zero which is sort of like the
effective initial value of n
and that gives you just two parameters
instead of one to two which is annoying
but this is often will give you much
much better results and i believe and
maybe someone will correct me if i'm
wrong this is the default setting and
scikit-learn for doing svds
just to use this setting for alpha
another one is the question about
momentum and this is averaging estimates
so i think it's actually easier to just
show it um so this is exactly the same
rule we did for linear regression but
here's this polyacryl averaging
so let me just sort of show what really
matters the trick is that instead of
just containing
beta as a solution beta is actually
going to be this like kind of tacky
intermediate solution and our real
solution is going to be c
and then every iteration we do the
normal sgd pass which i'm here calling
polyacpath but that's exactly what you
saw before
to update beta but at every point in
time then what i do is i set
c my real solution c is
an average of my previous version of c
and then the current update i have to be
and this is like momentum so if it's not
exactly the same but it's a sort of
similar sphere and if you sit down and
write out the expansions you'll see that
it's basically averaging out
averaging out gradients over time and
this thing turns out
in my experience to be ridiculously
better than sort of black box sgd
um sort of considering how cheap it is a
solution it's sort of so little worth to
do it
it turns out in my experience it would
solve a lot of the really awful
instabilities that you can sometimes get
in these things
so that's one way you might try to solve
the other some of these problems
and the last thing i'm going to mention
before i stop is a per parameter step
size and this is
out of grad yep so actually all the
things that matter about autograd are
right here
so like before we're going to randomly
draw
j which observation we're going to
analyze we've got our head you know our
hypothesis h
our prediction we've got a residual the
difference between the truth and our
hypothesis
but here's what's going to happen we're
going to update the gradients like we
were doing every time before
and then what we have is this additional
thing that we store s
and s is just the sum of the squared
entries and the gradients we've seen so
far so that's what
s of i plus plus equals g r of i
so at every point in time so at time n
s for feature one is the sum of the
squared entry in the gradient for
feature 1
and every other point from from 1 up to
n minus 1.
so this is just giving some sense of the
scale of the gradient
and the scale of the gradient is related
to the scale of that feature
and so this is just giving you some
sense of the scale of that feature
and then what you do then is you set
beta to be
like eta times the gradients but
shrunken down
by the size of the sums of the previous
gradients
and that sum has two and that sum has
two nice properties one is it deals with
a per
parameter feature problem which is some
of the features are big and some of them
are small
that solves that problem and also this
because this sum gradually increases as
n increases
is actually like a hackish way of also
decreasing like one over
n this also which is not obvious but it
also has the property that this thing
gradually goes towards zero
and so this this avigrad trick and this
was very
very highly recommended to me by alex
astos
and so i sort of very very strongly
prefer it
this thing i find is sort of this mixed
with some polyethylene averaging
goes goes a really long way to making
this usable in practice
right no so these are all mutating
functions that's what that explanation
so i'm
i'm editing b in place and then just
returning void
this is very like this is our c style
julia code
and that's actually i believe um well
yeah so i guess i'll let people ask
questions first and then i'll sort of
say my last three things and then have
broader questions
is there a good recommended way to
calculate standard errors
uh for the estimates of these things
yeah where's the distinction
well the sdg is generally used in cases
in which what we really want is
predictions
not true estimates of parameters um
there probably is literature on that but
i'm not familiar with it
um in large part because basically every
paper i've ever written on the read not
never written any gay response every
paper i've ever read on this topic has
been written by a machine learning
person
and machine learning people just don't
care about standard errors
and so i i think sort of sense that i
think
they may exist papers that have talked
about how to do that but i've never read
any of them um
if someone knows one i would love to
hear about it but i'm not aware that
they even exist
let alone the sort of car usable
sorry yeah this is the scd very much
comes from machine learning culture it
very much comes from people who are just
trying to make predictions at sort of
massive scales and
they're sometimes sort of throwing some
topics on the business
well all my examples are like that but
you could just be processing it where
every iteration you're just processing
one and it's not randomly selected
you're just pretending like it was
randomly selected
you just use the newest thing and that
actually in that context
which is the virtue of setting alpha for
the via constants in that context where
you're just
accepting the newest data this model
because you're having out to be a
constant will be like an exponentially
weighted average of those values you
should
have them for the parameters and so when
say
summer comes and people suddenly have
different behavior than they had in
winter
the model will shift to be a new type of
model and so that's how sort of we'll
deal with the back of the data is not
actually random is that
the constant outflow will actually fix
that problem somewhat
it creates other problems but it fixes
that one
yeah they're basically the same thing
alpha was what i used in the original
equations and then eight is what i was
using in these equations
and you had a question yeah this has
seen three
optimizations
uh they're probably all so the question
was does heshton free optimization have
something to do with this
i didn't have not yet read a paper on
using hessian-free methods for
stochastic gradient descent
but there probably will be one soon
since it sort of sounds obviously like
the title of a nips paper
um so hfp methods are just sort of a
trick for not having to store the whole
hessian and so they're pretty great
tools
but i don't i've never used one so i've
never coded it so i don't know the
details
but my sense is that they're pretty
involved iterative calculations
and so they're kind of hard to do in
this streaming context
there's probably someone who's going to
figure it out but it's sort of
not obvious to me how to get them to
work
but probably at some point they will
exist and be usable
um and that's actually very closely
related to this thing which is variants
of quasi-newtonian methods so
there have been people creating things
that sort of approximate not just the
gradient online but the hessian online
um i've never gotten those i've never
coded them up at all so i had no idea
that they wouldn't work but i've never
sort of
read through a paper like i can easily
implement this in five minutes
and sort of written the code to do it my
sense is that they probably are much
better than what i presented but they're
probably also a lot harder
but anything that's going to be able to
sort of tell you about correlations
between
parameters which the hessian is going to
give you some of that information
in general is going to probably give you
better behavior
um but i also i once brought this up in
a conversation with yesterday with rob
shapiro about why you might want that
and i think he made an interesting point
which is very sort of ml's
response which is well you really need
the hessian if you want to get exactly
the right coefficients
but the response was well i don't really
ever care about the exact right
coefficients of the correlate if the
features are that correlated
because sort of many different settings
of the coefficients would have been just
as good as
and so one reason why maybe you don't
need the hessian is that maybe for the
purpose of prediction is sort of
irrelevant
i mentioned this idea of automatic
learning rate tuning
so this is some papers that john
lankford has which is saying sort of how
how how do you actually set data in some
automatic way
i think that stuff probably in the next
five to ten years will be
sort of largely solved and this will be
just technology that's sort of black
boxable right now you do actually need
to think a lot about this before you run
this in production
but i think people will start to solve
this problem
and then the final one which is to make
this thing
really run nice often to get a great
solution you actually don't want to
totally stream the data but you want to
make a more than one pass through all of
it
so you want to take some big thing
stream it row by row
so you actually need to make more than
one pass to get through it
and figuring out how many passes we need
to make is also another question
i think that's sort of the other big
problem that comes up on this and
there are a bunch of papers uh that are
all basically i mean
the holy grail of this literature to be
very clear the holy grail of this is to
eventually figure out completely
automatic techniques that you don't have
to make more than one pass to your data
to get the right model fix
people are getting there but they're
sort of not yet there and it really
depends on what data you have whether
you could get away with less than one
whole pass of the data so my sort of
approach
problem
well so i guess there's two contexts um
so one is you could you could write out
you can write down a sub gradient for
lasso and there is a paper showing how
to solve the lasso streaming
so sort of if you like lasso you can
still get lasso to work in this context
the other question is storing this
buffer which i assume you mean by like
sub-sampling your data
taking a subset so that actually is very
related to this you can actually
instead of looking at a single
observation look at many of them at once
and that's called a mini match
and a lot of this literature talks about
how to do analysis of many batches
the real question that i think is
relevant is
is your goal to go through your
historical data
and then sub randomly subsample
historical data and find a good model
and that's often
like a totally reasonable goal but if
that's your goal
just do that the context in which i
think this is more relevant
is is not necessarily that frequent to
context it actually occurs but when it
does
is i actually want to be really
genuinely incrementing this model
every time that i have say new customers
arrive and i want to be able to make
predictions quickly for that one new
customer who arrives
and that's the case where i don't really
want to substantial data i want to be
able to make updates for them
quickly and i think that that context is
one that we sort of have not yet really
reached
because it's very hard to make these
things fast enough to actually do that
that's sort of that's the idealized
vision of the context where you're
not going to randomly sub sample data
but instead you're going to try to do it
in the streaming fashion
but which one i mean which one works it
really sort of depends on the details of
what you can pull off
like if you if you can pull off things
like this they often are much better say
trying to run a multi-arm band of tests
than
than doing random sub sampling but it
really really really depends on
the specific details of your application
did that seem like a reasonable but
probably not great answer
okay cool um so i'm actually going to
stop because sort of want to get through
this material fairly quickly and i feel
like it's
probably really late and it is um
so if there are any closing questions or
otherwise sort of you can talk to me at
the bar
uh i see you know closing questions so
what's up so we're gonna have so yeah so
we're heading up to rye house that will
be the bar
that if you want to come ask me a
question or just hang out and take for a
little bit
we'll be there i think it's at 17th
street right
yeah so 17th between west and 5th and
we'll be
there in a few minutes all right thanks
everybody